okay people joining this livestream this
is a late-breaking piece of
functionality for version 12 of off
language this is a function called web
crawl map and why does it say new and
11.2 it certainly wasn't know
Sarah that's lawful okay I'm okay
okay let's take a look at this
functionality then
so if I say why is that still blue that
doesn't seem like a good sign to me why
is it still blue here
chuckles I don't know was it blue in
your build it seems absolutely nothing
what is it there was an issue with auto
auto loading and I I did a lab they went
today's build Steven I think so
let's find out October 27th so it might
not be I can go to the prototype build
should I go to the prototype build I
think so yes
Nicholas you got your build today right
that was working yes this should have
been today's build unless what the very
least I think you can call needs web
chrome apps the pack looks definitely
there okay well let me just do that let
me do that here um could we try to mute
please
Nicholas oh the pack let's
called web crawl hope no it's not okay
Nikko's what do we do here is there I
don't know wife love it what's it called
well called just web crawl yes okay
let's try the prototype built seriously
is that the packets been in the build
for a couple weeks now okay this is
looking promising okay there we go
okay let's start looking at the design
him okay because the list of the results
were playing f2 an association for each
web object found by crawling the web
starting at route that sounds like my
writing hopefully it wasn't that way
somebody else sounds just like me yeah
so we fixed a couple of the options
option and parameter descriptions too
much I would put much death up there
okay so the default shouldn't blow it
blow itself up I would say okay
is there anything
just bother we could be putting in here
I could try to do something I tried
something but it was there was some
issue because of the uses of a
synchronous stuff and there were some
glitches so our error removed so what is
this doing it's crawling the web site
and it should print I know you've got
max items thing there yes I mean two
little ways of limiting ensues a simpler
website here this isn't terribly
encouraging why isn't this coming back
faster do we have any reason to think
it's working at all yes yes yes Nicholas
was adding the tables today yes so it
was working with a build he was not
local branch or anything he downloaded
it from our system ok you should not
need some weird link extraction option
here it is needed because of how the
world from dot-com website is designed
the example there I should use a
different website or different because
the website uses a very weird scheme in
which they used query parameters to
to sign the source so you have different
pages that seem to be different pages
but they are the same page that's the
only language switching isn't it no no
it's like if you come from home page
then you have what just happened here
this crashed this didn't work so that's
not a good sign so let's try running it
again perfectly not I I don't know what
I've been using it without no problems
here Oh character encoding not a valid
character including what's the story
with that
but what Nicholas what is do you know
well I don't know what these it's
probably a URL read error isn't it well
if we can't get the more information if
we could show the stacktrace we would be
in good shape from character encoding
what is this this is something kind of
complicated look at this
from car
this thing , failed alright okay I don't
think I use tactical well something uses
it
yes I'm sure you're using like URL read
or something right Nicholas well think
you think it's import and some sometimes
yeah that's somehow the character
encoding for that is broken I mean I
think one of the things we're learning
is all of these web pages have all kinds
of detailed issues with them which is
why crawling is kind of hard okay but
but so in this case let's just go max
depth one all items let's just see
what's there okay I'm super surprised
those are the only links that are there
so let's let's to prove that let's do an
import on my front page does it care
between HTTP HTTP does it auto does it
automatically am cycle through those
okay I don't understand that why why
would this say hash URL
what does that mean max depth one
compared to hyperlinks there got my
question with lengths and tip you know
why well let's try max depth - butBut
look at those that there are plenty of
things here going off the domain right
yes there's an option called same hosts
is that defaulting to true yes okay so
let's try this again
I'll do it those are called same hosts
like this no no that's a link extraction
and then you can you pass options and
one of those processes encode that is
something I'm not why isn't link
extraction coming up is auto-completed
here maybe because it hasn't got your
documentation same host arrow false is
that right well now that's yet a
different list so let's do percent 4
percent 5 so let's say complement okay
all right why
not been followed so that was filed with
the import with hyperlinks I I will need
to go to the source of what weapons to
see this something that I'm not covering
wait you sure that it his SoundCloud
showed up well interesting so web chrome
map has HTTPS for the SoundCloud link or
as imports as HTTP for the SoundCloud
link yeah look at that
but here oh well wait a second but but I
mean yeah most of those are ones that
turn into GPS and the first one yeah but
the length of that length % 5 & % 4 yeah
something is exact match but I think
that explains part of it okay this 10
missing does tender here does this allow
both same host true and same host false
yes it obviously does oh I see I may see
something in there in the source code of
the web site that maybe explains this ah
you'd way of linking that is valid not
recommended but maybe I'm not supporting
it some links in the words in this
oversight arc slash slash domain they
don't have a scheme they they are slash
slash
stand well you'd better support it yep
okay you might and also let's report it
to the folks who maintain that website
yes maybe that's the Crawleys that's
messing up okay so let's go find can we
find any conforming website here every
website should most of all right give me
a website that I can crawl here using
their website before your book well from
science okay try that one I mean this is
in the in the bizarre theory of let's
find some thing that works here let's go
well let's say hash title just for fun
[Music]
so it works yeah so can I just say well
from science com
that's what
follows at most n levels so why does if
given that we have an N level thing why
do we have to say appear max depth
okay okay so let's say this no I mean
that's not in committed it's a it's a
natural in the domination
I should have implemented that okay so
it's an error
sorry yes it was something that last
meeting and I not see that look look
what happened here that's clearly wrong
yes I think that also titles is not the
title is not extractor I that's in this
list
yes it's an error okay and now also the
thing is why why is this not working
formatting notebook weird okay
so hash URL that seems something seemed
to crash there okay so now again I'm
going to do the test import with
hyperlinks African the whole
oh it's a turn-off same host so yeah
same host should probably be what should
the default let the Fox will be false
right well I don't know what people know
I mean it depends what you want if you
want to help roll they force a
particular side true because else you
will be crawling all all the web yeah
that's true
you usually want to crawl a specific
website that's more common now what's it
doing there we go okay
okay yes again we have more things than
hyperlinks lists than we do in the web
crawl list okay so do you in fact import
body or not I should review all of these
because I have been trying with a little
set and I should I will make sure that
all of this work thing
are we confident enough that this is
useful that we want to put it into
version 12 or is this really just gonna
be an embarrassment at this point but
the broken things certainly surprised me
today do you think UNCHR all should be
in our spelling dictionary I which were
not crawled knowing which URLs but not
not not yet called it's a bit obscure
but the the point of that option is that
the I when I try to create an index of a
very huge website
I needed this option so that I can I can
is this a new thing we have not
discussed yet no it was in it was
discussed but I don't know it some level
stupid did you add this documentation
yes curry world's function I think was
added by you Stephen but we didn't
completely finish but we didn't I didn't
write this I guarantee I did not write
this know that that you did not write it
was so what other stuff was not written
by me here and isn't marked as tentative
I think we they were marked marked that
it was okay so there was the XML object
well let's go through this one okay okay
applied to URLs discarded do to Max
items what the hell does that mean that
the function you passed with this option
will be applied to each URL that is not
being crawled because the limit of
maximum URLs to grow has been reached
yeah okay I your but it's useful when
you want to split the job into Moodle
smaller so I don't think it's the right
way to do it
I really don't think it's the right way
to do it whoops why did that do that
that's really crazy um I just don't
think it's probably thought out that
this is I understand roughly what you're
trying what is this doing there's no
what now I know it was happening to
Nikolas in me this morning we couldn't
that's why the tags aren't right we
thought it was us this appears to be
totally confused
so there's something wrong in this
version with the sum let's see we can
put it in here oh come on
well okay so somebody has got to add
this here
okay did I hope you reported the bug
with these tag feeling added in the
wrong place I can now I thought it just
me not knowing how to use da key tools
but yeah I'll report it
oh for goodness sake come on
so somebody okay alright okay so I don't
think this is right okay listen this is
this function too primitive to even make
it into twelve oh thank you I thought I
was gonna get could go to twelve but I
think I should go to twelve one after
having this meeting I do too let's
refuse it I don't think I don't think
we're ready here I think I think it's
gotta have fun
okay so let's with that in mind um
yeah I mean there multiple issues here I
mean first thing is I mean is it
reasonably fast or is it is it slow as
as anything
last okay so if I if I want to for
example let's stay on this domain where
I really don't think there's any
particular let's just go this will be
same host
let's try to max depth to for example
okay this is really very slow and the
fact that it's doing no indication of
what it's doing is really disappointing
so what is it actually doing is it is it
initiating asynchronous tasks to do this
or what
you understand my question Nicholas how
is it doing this is it doing over they
synchronous tasks or what
because okay we're gonna have to give up
this meeting if we can't get to it does
use asynchronous tasks yeah I understand
that but I mean this is so let's go to
Mac step three I see him muting and
unmuting but it's obviously not working
oh sorry I was using them sorry
this is using your assumed it
everything is fetcher a synchronously in
several threads at the time okay I mean
it's a bit too you know so slow because
this has affected the content of every
one of these latest okay so notice that
it's saying this so why is it saying
that why is it why does it think there's
a dynamic warning why is it using is
that using some service kernel somewhere
how is the submission working is the
submission being is some kind of session
submit thing or what
it's a submit okay why is it doing this
just that what's happening is so I just
aborted there my guess is what's
happening is that the URL submit is
somehow using trying to use some
pre-emptive link some service kernel on
a pre-emptive link to do something
our goodness sake
you know hunts
on the livestream points out some
examples which work use HTTP as the base
whereas this is using HTTP it's just
very unclear what this is doing whether
it's pushing over automatically to HTTPS
or what it's doing I mean okay there
clearly needs to be a bunch will work
here I don't know
okay was URL sad I don't know I have
used it to index the whole of the
world's number effect successfully I
don't know why this is not why it's
failing for me okay so okay well I don't
know I mean maybe it's a prototype build
that has other things broken it I don't
really know um no maybe needs more
testing well Matt what should we do here
I mean are we
oh if you'd like 12:1 I think we should
wait till 12:00 1:00 and we should work
more I need to work more heavily with QA
I think because apparently a lot of
cases that were not thought through by
me or by Nicolas for how to test this
fine fine okay alright let's wrap it up
then for right now right here on this
and um and that's everybody go work on
the freeze for 12 Oh which um okay I'll
push back whatever I changed here into
the into the repository otherwise great
thanks okay see y'all soon